welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course not David Pakman but
Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
addictions show and host of like it or
not for content news which are the
studios that you see around me
David is traveling as a to a conference
and I am here covering for him he'll be
back for the rest of the week
broadcasting remotely there's a story
that is so fascinating to me over the
weekend a group of psychologists about a
hundred people most of them were
psychologists gathered together and
marched in New York City to bring
attention to Donald Trump's mental
health issues but particularly to call
for his impeachment based on the 25th
amendment stating that he's he's just
unfit he's unfit to be the President of
the United States you would have seen
the image on your screen of the
psychologists marching they are part of
a group called duty to warn now this
goes against a long-held standard that
has been in place since 1964 called the
Goldwater rule where psychologists were
told that they should not give any type
of psychological analysis of public
figures particularly without examining
them first and this was put into place
because of Barry Goldwater people
attempted to use his public information
in his speeches to try to diagnose him
and use that as a means of opposition
well that rule was lifted by the
American Psychological analytic
Association it was lifted specifically
because of Donald Trump and the reason
they lifted it was because a lot of
their members felt that they had a duty
to warn Americans about the narcissistic
personality disorder that Donald Trump
has now a lot of times when we say
narcissism we kind of throw it around
casually but in the psycho psychological
realm it has a very specific meaning
with very very important implications as
far as the severity of it and there's a
couple of quotes that I want to bring up
on your on your screen now the first one
says that quote we can sense the power
of trumps underlying fear that he is
worthless and weak by how intensely he
resists and retaliate we tally
against any criticism and that's Harry
Segal a Cornell University psychologist
and so that was one of the first steps
in moving towards this direction of
making an analysis a cycle analysis of
who Donald Trump is and but more
specifically why it's dangerous and I
think this next quote actually sums it
up even better I will pull that up on
your screen now and this is a clinical
psychologist Michelle Garland she said
quote no matter how minor he can't let
anything go
we're actually suffering from his
narcissistic personality he has no
empathy you can feel it the way he spoke
about the San Juan mayor she has PTSD
and our president mistreats her she is
riebeck demised that is a narcissist and
so the group got together and they
marched over the weekend bringing
attention to not only bringing attention
to Donald Trump's personality disorder
but also calling for his impeachment now
this is not this is not an attempt to
shame people who have mental health
issues right mental health issues exist
across the United States of America that
does not preclude one from running for
higher office and I think that's one of
the reasons of the original 1964
Goldwater rule is because a lot of times
as you bring attention to a public
figure you inadvertently bring
condemnation towards people who may also
have that similar type of personality
disorder however the danger of Donald
Trump being the level of narcissists
that he is can't be understated such as
why we see these psychologists taking to
the street I mean really think about
that psychologists first of all the the
APA waived this 1964 Goldwater rule
because they felt like they had a duty
to free up all 3500 of their members
psychologists to allow them to speak
very frankly about what they believe
they can ascertain from any videos of
Donald Trump that's the first thing and
now you have this March from the group
duty to warn who they're screaming at
the top of their lungs to try to let
America know that we have a president
who is causing America to suffer that
and I think that's one of the most
important distinctions there right so
narcissism
as a way of affecting the people around
it more so than the individual suffering
by themselves it causes suffering around
them and we see now that will you have a
President of the United States who is as
narcissistic as Donald Trump he has the
ability to inflict massive pain on to
other people either out of sheer desire
or because according to Michelle Garland
a lack of empathy Donald Trump does not
care about anybody else but Donald Trump
we could just cut to the chase
right and I think one of the key
components of being a leader of being
the president of the United States is
being able to pause and set your
interests aside to fill the empathy of
the people that you serve Donald Trump
is utilizing the White House to serve
him he has zero concern about serving
other people and while that may may
sound cliche it is best personified by
how he is not able to take down he's not
able to take criticism he's willing to
disrupt any part of the government he is
willing to disrupt any part of the
government in order to satisfy his
narcissism he will fire anybody who
disagrees with them he will fire anyone
who gets more spotlight than him
consider that think about every person
who for a moment got more attention than
Donald Trump and you will see that
Donald Trump shortly thereafter fired
that individual and that is
destabilizing that has the ability to
put the United States uniquely in a
vulnerable position in a in a situation
where this could backfire in a very
spectacular and dangerous way and that's
why these psychologists I believe firmly
that's why they've taken to the streets
and decided to call for the impeachment
of Donald Trump based on his mental
health condition the extent to which he
is a narcissist such that he is causing
pain intentionally on the American
people just to satisfy his narcissism
this is who this is who they elected you
know this is this is who and I'm
surprised that people couldn't see this
before some psychologists had to point
this out I mean some things should just
be common sense right some things don't
require psychoanalysis some things you
can just look at Donald Trump and
realize
everything about his life has been to
service himself and never to be a public
servant and everything about his life
has been to services ego and now we have
that type of disorder in the White House
and again this is not to this is not to
shame anyone else who's dealing with any
type of mental health disorder but we
have to be cognizant of the fact that
the man who has the most power in the
world is there to please no one but
himself at the expense of everyone
around him that should terrify us even
more than his agenda right now his
agenda is damned is downright terrifying
but his disorder his his narcissism
should terrify us because of to what
extent he's willing to go to satisfy it
we'll be back right after this